and she'll talk on improved learning
from all growth complexity
all right uh hi everybody
um yes my name is Haley if we haven't
met and I'm just going to be talking
about this project that Valentine
cabinets and I have been working on
recently it's called improved learning
from time-bounded clemograph complexity
um Okay so we've heard earlier in the
program how there's this sort of
interesting connection going on between
pseudorandomeness and learning
so they seem to be somehow at odds with
one another there's like a sense in
which one of them is only possible if
the other is impossible
um okay so I'm gonna illustrate that
Phenomenon with this uh very simple
generator
um which I'll call generator number one
it's just like an M wise uh direct
product of this function f
so you can think of these
um X size as strings of length n coming
from some distribution and F is just a
Boolean function applied to those
strings
okay so it's pretty well known by this
um
connection of Yao between
distinguishability and predictability
that this generator is not pseudo-random
if and only if you can efficiently
distinguish its outputs from the um
string with uniform distribution in the
last M bits a phenomena if you can
predict
um
the values of
um f of x given a prefix of the
generator so you can sort of predict it
with probability a bit better than
randomly guessing uh over that whatever
distribution the excise come from
okay so already in this statement of
prediction it kind of has like the
flavor of learning right because what's
happening we um we get some excise along
with the corresponding values of f on
those X I's so it's like some random
random examples of F and then we're able
to say something about an unseen value
of f so like we're sort of weekly
learning f
um to be a bit more precise about the
kind of learning that I'm talking about
so this is
um Valiants probably approximately
correct learning
um there's a learner and it's um trying
to learn some unknown Target concept F
which is like a Boolean function
um F belongs to a concept class C which
you could think of as like the set of
functions computable by circuits of some
polynomial size
and then what does the learner get it
gets some random samples X drawn
according to the Target distribution d
as well as the corresponding values of f
on those inputs X okay and then the goal
is to produce with high probability a
hypothesis H that approximates F well
over the distribution d
foreign
there's a natural generalization of this
model called agnostic pack learning
um so we're still learning with respect
to a fixed concept class but now F might
not belong to the uh that class so F can
be arbitrary
um it's probably too much to ask now
that in polytime we could approximate
some arbitrary F very well but at least
we could hope to do as well as the best
concept that does belong to C so trying
to approximate F almost optimally with
respect to C
and then there's also this um relaxation
of the model in which the learner is
allowed to ask membership queries to the
Target function so at any time in the
learning process it can come up with any
string why that it likes and ask for the
value of f on that input y
so there's this um result of karmacino
in pagliatso cabinets and coca-lova
which is kind of um exploiting that
antagonism between learning and
pseudorandomeness
okay so it says that if there's a
natural proof of a circuit lower bound
like in the sense of rasparov and rudish
um then you can pack learn over that
same circuit class uh over the uniform
distribution and it'll require
membership queries
so I'll just try to give like a little
bit of intuition as to where the
requirement of membership queries is
coming from
so let's say we have a natural property
let's try to use it to break this simple
generator one that I started with and
we'll see what's going to happen
okay so we're learning over the uniform
distribution so we'll say that these
xi's are uniformly random
um okay and the goal would be to use a
natural property to distinguish this
from uniform
um so we would want to show that the
outputs of this generator would have
small smaller than trivial circuits if
if they're interpreted as a truth table
so yes that the excis are uniformly
random so we probably can't hope to
compress those very much
um but we know f is computable by a
small circuit so intuitively you might
think that using that fact you could
compress this this string say if you
took M to be like sufficiently larger
than the circuit size of f
um okay but if you actually tried to
construct a circuit doing that
um you'd see that it doesn't really work
because this amount of Randomness at the
beginning is so long just the amount of
like circuitry multiplexers you would
need to take the appropriate x i and put
it into the circuit Computing f it would
overwhelm those M bits at the end that
you had to work with
okay which is why
um the authors of cikkk head to resort
to the slightly more
um complicated construction of Nissan
and bigerson
so yeah I guess the most important thing
here is that now
the random seed Zedge is allowed to be
much shorter than the stretch of the
generator
and it's just um
kind of you the randomness is used very
like economically and that a small
amount of Randomness is kind of reused
and reused to get different values of f
okay so you can kind of think of this as
like a de-randomized version of the
generator one that we started with or
you could think of generator one as a
really inefficient
design free version of this generator
um okay but the idea is that when
interpreted as a truth table outputs of
this generator have smaller than trivial
circuits so we can break the generator
and then just by a hybrid argument we
can then
predict the values of some unseen uh f
with Z sub I skipping
a prefix okay and by the way since Zed
is uniformly distributed
um those Zeds are restricted to fsis are
just also uniformly distributed which is
what we want
um right which brings me to what's with
the membership queries well once um
once a learner fixes a choice of
Randomness
um there are some very specific values
of F that it would need to know based on
that randomness
um in order to construct like the the
part of a hybrid
so it's not enough is in the case of
generator one to just have some any
random uh values of f it has to be some
very specific ones
um that depend on said okay
true
yeah
independent of the restricted to S1 they
hear a few
comments
it's a comment even if you fix all the
others if you didn't know
what those what the comments are
great yeah thank you so it's like yeah
these uh NW designs outside right like
they don't overlap too much but they
they overlap sorry what what are you
proving about
um I'm just explaining why the cik paper
needed um to be able to test membership
but what is the result but
um that if natural properties exists you
can do Pac learning providity of
membership grades
okay so that's kind of high level but
that's the intuition
um so some follow-up works of
um Extended cfk in different ways
um so the same authors the next year
um show that you can also do agnostic
pack learning if there's a kind of
suitable
generalization of natural properties
uh more recently this paper from
Benedict chromosino
coliclova Ramya and Sabin
um showed not only uniform distribution
but you can learn over an arbitrary
efficiently sample distribution
there is a caveat which is that the
learner needs to know the code of a
sampler for that distribution
okay but I mean in the case that D is
just polytime sampleable that's not too
much of an imposition it's just a
constant number of bits how is the code
used
um I'm gonna talk about that quite a bit
later so I'll answer that later
so another way to think about natural
properties of course as a in terms of
this minimum circuit size problem so
picking our definitions appropriately
the existence of natural properties is
just equivalent to average cases units
of mcsp so this is just a restatement of
the cfk Care result it's the same thing
um we've also heard a lot about these
problems for time-bounded common core of
complexity so there's a k superscript t
like K poly and then there's um
allenders K capital T they're related to
Circuit size right like um okay capital
T you can kind of think of it as a kind
of a relaxation of circuit size and that
it does away with the requirement that a
small description of a string be like
interpreted as a Boolean circuit so
there's a little more flexibility
intuitively
um we've also heard that these problems
are sometimes easier to work with which
is a little bit of foreshadowing for the
next slide
um which is that we're able what we're
able to prove
um if there's a k-pauli or k capital T
like analog of a natural property then
you can do agnostic pack learning
over any efficiently sample distribution
and you no longer need membership
queries
so just learning from random examples
so I'll just be a bit more precise
um it's average case usiness over the
uniform distribution that's just an
analogy with what a natural property is
um and then we're assuming like either
sort of one-sided or better yet
errorless definition of
um average case easiness so we'd need
that all yes instances of these problems
um are always going to be accepted at
least with high probability
um as I said the only access to the
Target function you get is through
randomly drawn labeled examples
but there is a difference between the
two cases in terms of the type of access
you would get to the Target distribution
um so in the top case of K poly
all you need to know is an upper bound
on the complexity of that distribution
so say if you knew those parameters T
and A then you could learn over any
distribution that's sample in time a or
t with a bits of advice
um okay but in the bottom case of K
capital T it's the same situation I
described before where it's like a
stronger form of access to the
distribution you need to know the code
of a sampler
I'm so sorry to do this to you just um
bear with me for a minute uh I'll Define
okay polio Vex denoted case superscript
T so you can think of it as
um what's the minimum length of a
description that you could possibly send
to a
some entity that can only run for
t-steps such that it could recover the
string X
there's also a probabilistic
um version of K poly where you'd think
now of the sender and receiver is being
in the presence of some shared
Randomness and now the descriptions D
are allowed to depend on that randomness
so what's the minimum length s such that
with high probability over Randomness
there's some description of like this
which in the presence of the randomness
yields the string X in time t
so it's like looking a bit like the
definite definition of am and that like
Witnesses are allowed to depend on
randomness
um and then of course this one's the
most important complexity measure of the
day because it's um allenders K capital
T so now we're asking about whether the
string X is
um efficiently locally computable
so this decompressor
um on the left only needs one bit of X
at a time it's allowed to
um make random access queries to the
description D and now the amount of time
T it takes is explicitly uh counted in
the complexity of x
okay so now we'll talk a bit more about
how our proofs work so they're both
working
um by the these known reductions from um
Pac learning to these problems that are
called random right hand side refutation
so
um there are a couple different versions
of this but this is kind of the simpler
one from photon
so what is this problem well we got some
labeled examples x i comma bi so the
exciser strings from some distribution D
the bis are bits labeling the X size and
then all our theater has to do is
distinguish between these two cases so
in the first case the bis are just
independently uniformly random
and then in the other case the bis are
consistent with some small circuit
um applied to the excise
different now
[Music]
that could be a piece um for p slash
poly sound
like so just some idea of how the
reduction works why if you can do this
can you do
um pack learning well it just it's um
the same reason that you can do some
learning if you break that first
generator that I was talking about right
so I think it's kind of clear that if
you can solve this problem
um you can break that generator it's
just kind of a rewriting of the same
thing distinguishing whether the the
labels are random or the outputs of a
small circuit
um if you can do that then you can at
least weekly
um learn that function f over the
distribution D and if you want to boost
it and get like a stronger learner that
um
that moves up a lot better
um then okay you can be boosting and the
distribution will change a bit but
if you can refute over all of psamp then
you can also agnostically learn over all
of psamp
but it's like distribution uh
independent in that sense
okay and then there's this other version
um that was
given independently by kotari and livni
and it's been called correlative random
right hand side refutation so it's just
kind of a version of the problem that
turns out to be equivalent to agnostic
pack learning
so everything's the same here except in
the sound soundness case you know the
bis aren't exactly
um the values of f on the X size but
they are
correlated with those values
oh
here are we still assuming like
all the exercises are independent and
the in the labels are independent
or excited like they just
adversarial which see eyes are going to
equal the label it's everything's
independent
okay and then yeah also kind of by a
hybrid argument
um you can show that if you can do this
reputation problem
um then you can agnostically uh clear an
f and the nice thing about the agnostic
setting is that there are there's a
distribution specific boosting so if we
can refute over this one distribution we
can strongly agnostically pack learn
over the same distribution
now I'm gonna claim that with these
tools in hand under our assumptions it's
already easy to learn over the uniform
distribution
okay so for example let's assume that
allenders KT is easy on average and see
what happens
okay so now the X i's are independently
uniformly random so are the bis so if we
concatenate them all into one big long
string call it X comma B well we know
that with very high probability over
uniformly random strings that those
strings will have almost maximum KT
complexity so on the random random side
the whole string is uniformly random
probably well fkt complexity about its
length
um and now I want to show that in the
correlative case
um there's some KT compression going on
okay so the excise are still uniformly
random no hope of compressing those
but
um
but once we have the excise we can kind
of show that it'll be easier to compute
the B's
so what do we do we will give ourselves
enough bits to write down all of X and
we give ourselves enough bits to write
down the size of a circuit that computes
F and that's a step in the right
direction right because if we want some
bi we we could just look up the
corresponding X I run it through the
circuit for f and then we have the value
of f on x sub I so
um okay but that's not quite enough of
course because the bis aren't always
correct with respect to f
um so that's where this term comes in
which is
um kind of encoding the indices I where
the bis are in correction
um I won't go into too much detail but
it turns out to be a little bit KT
compressible
um you can choose them to be a large
enough polynomial in N
um
so that like um for sure outweighs the
size of the circuit for f and you get
the desired Gap in KT between the two
cases which your your stick for for KT
can identify and output random or
correlative
why is it
in order m to the three fourths oh okay
so
the M that you picked is exactly the
same as the advantage in the correlation
or it's related to that
um yes
[Music]
right so that's why I was wondering why
it wasn't like him
you have to like pick the end to be
about that the first knowledge and
negative ad to the fourth hour or
something oh yeah that's right that's
right yeah
okay so let's see
um what goes wrong if we try to apply
the same argument to learn over other
distributions
um okay there are a couple problems and
one is that we've only assumed we have a
heuristic that works over the uniform
distribution
um and that's fine in the correlative
case because of a nice one-sided uh
error property we've assumed
um but in the random case now the excise
aren't uniformly random and we have no
reason to believe our heuristics gonna
work very well
um okay and then the other issue is that
with the excise being sampled according
to D there is no reason to think that
their KT complexity is likely to be
large anymore
um so we'll have to think of some way to
get around that
um which is where this paper from
schwichi hirahara and mikito nanoshima
comes in
um so it's kind of providing a framework
to get around those obstacles that I
mentioned
they're working under the assumption of
distributional NP being an average p and
then they're able to get the same kind
of conclusion that we get in the case of
our uh okay poly result
so that like Cuts our workout for us
right we want to try to apply their
framework under under this weaker
starting assumption
okay so I'll just say a little bit about
that framework
um this is kind of the first ingredient
of it so under that assumption this
average case easiness assumption you can
prove a worst case approximation
algorithm for K poly so for any string X
you can efficiently compute a value s
that is like some sort of estimate of K
poly of x
okay and then the second ingredient is a
weak symmetry of information theorem uh
for K poly so it's its worst case uh
with respect to the string X but for any
string x with high probability over a
uniformly random y uh K poly of X and Y
together will be roughly at least K poly
of X plus the length of Y
so the second ingredient I'll just apply
it immediately to this refutation
problem
so it just tells us right away in the
random case that K poly of X and B
together is going to be roughly at least
K poly of X plus the length of b
um okay and I'll just move some of these
terms over a bit and this shows how we
would use the first ingredient which is
the approximation algorithm for K poly
so we would estimate the values of K
poly of x k poly of X and B together
subtract them compare them with
threshold and
output and answer
um okay but if you're paying close
attention you might see that there's
some sort of issue in that uh the cape
polyovic stream has different time
balance on the two two sides
um and that that's necessary given the
weak symmetry of information and the
argument that we used in the correlative
case so how do we get around this
um
well the authors give what I think is a
really uh elegant and Powerful way
around this
um so it says that well under the uh
average case using this assumption
um for any efficiently sample
distribution d uh for sufficiently large
time-bound T so like a big enough
polynomial in and say and for X sampled
according to D the expected difference
between K poliovix and time unbounded K
of X is not going to be too large
so it'll just be some error that depends
like on the complexity of the
distribution
um it's not too much for us because we
can choose a number of samples m that
like far far outweighs this
um but yeah the upshot is that with high
probability we don't have to care too
much about the differences between kpt
of X and KT over 2 of X because
[Music]
um
there's just this nice sort of smoothing
out effect and the expectation both are
going to be close enough to just K of x
something
[Music]
so
now I'll just say a little bit about
um
kind of how we step from an average case
um assumption to like a worst case
conclusion
so we want to show that some strings y
have K poly compression via this sort of
um generator
reconstruction this is um what chewichi
was talking about earlier this um direct
product generator but we want to use the
Reconstruction of reconstruction
property of this generator to show that
K poly of Y is compressible okay so we
take a string Y and we encode it in this
generator and we set things up in a way
that we know
there's a distinguisher between that
generator and the uniform distribution
and then the nice thing about the
generator of course is it's
reconstruction property
um so it can give us back the string y
that we started with uh although it's
randomized
but that's okay if distributional NP is
an average p uh because by Burman 495 we
have de-randomization
so we can de-randomize this
reconstruction procedure
the randomness R becomes fixed and then
the required advice string for Y which
depended on R also becomes fixed
um so we have that there are some short
advice string Alpha that the
can compute Y in polynomial time
okay but of course this doesn't work
anymore under our weaker assumption we
don't have deerandomization
um the randomness R is kind of Long
Alpha depends on the randomness so it
certainly doesn't seem like there's a
any uh K poly compression happening for
y
[Music]
um
but it turns out what we do get is
probabilistic k-poly compression so the
definition of a PK poly
fits the situation perfectly and that's
not actually an accident but
um we have that with high probability
over Randomness R uh there's some short
description namely Alpha of Y and R
um that can compete Y in polytime in the
presence of r
okay so this this is what we have to
work with right now let's try to just
plug it into the framework of uh
hirohara nanashima and see what comes
out
um okay so we still get a worst case
algorithm that
does something but okay now for any
string X we can get a value s that's
kind of sandwiched in between like PK
poly of X and K poly of x
um so uh priori this doesn't look like
it would be very helpful because in
general PK poly and K poly can be as far
apart as you'd like there's nothing
tying them together
um okay so how do we get around this
well the idea would be to use something
like this slide I showed earlier which
says that in the expectation the KT of X
will be roughly K of X
um one thing we know about pkt is that
it's always smaller than KT and it's
always larger than time unbounded k
so if we had a statement like this it
would immediately give us that we don't
need to worry too much about these
differences between KT and pkt because
with high probability they'll be close
enough
um with high probability that
approximation algorithm will be good
enough for our purposes
okay but of course
we can't show this exactly without the
um
assumption with all event p
um but it turns out that we can show
something uh that looks a bit similar
um okay and I I won't go into the exact
reason of why we can't show this it has
to do with the uh Source coding theorem
for K poly that you can prove under this
assumption okay but without that we can
show that
um this holds so it's exactly the same
except now it requires so this presence
of this uniformly random string r
but the expected difference over X
sampled from d and uniformly random R of
that difference between K poly of xandar
K of X and R is not going to be too big
okay so yeah what do we do with this
totally unconditional
okay
disconnect
Ed
is it is it like a conditional
expectation of the gap between these
measures for the pressure
I mean it's not it's not conditional
this is the expectation of a random bar
um but yeah we do with the randomness we
just incorporate it into the future
algorithm itself
so the computer is allowed to be a
randomized entity it has plenty of a
uniform Randomness at its disposal so it
can just sample an art and then um use
that worst case approximation algorithm
to estimate K poly of X and R okay poly
of x b and R
um and it turns out that the gap between
the two sides is
um still in intact after the
modification there
okay yeah so there's this one other
issue I haven't addressed yet which is
uh the weak symmetry of information
theorem
um admittedly
there might be different ways around
this so you can maybe imagine a solution
like the one I I explained before you
could have PK Poly on one side K Poly on
the other side or something like that
um but I think a nicer way around it is
just to observe that you don't need this
kind of statement at all and it's just
for the same uh reason I've been citing
the expected closeness of time-bounded
and time unbounded K complexity
you can just apply the you know fact of
symmetry of information for time
unbounded chromograph complexity
so that's all I have to say about the K
poly result so now I'll switch gears to
the second one uh for alenders KT
just to review the situation
[Music]
um we don't have a lot of those tools
that we had in the case of K poly like a
worst average reduction or KT
compression via generator reconstruction
okay so already really have to work with
now is that assumed you're a stick for
mktp and it only works over the uniform
distribution
okay but at least we know that we can
learn over the uniform distribution from
this assumption so our goal now becomes
to reduce the task of learning over an
arbitrary distribution to that of
learning over the uniform distribution
do that we use a distributional
Inversion from pagliazzo and loopy
um this was used in a similar way in
that paper of Benedict at all that I
mentioned earlier so it's kind of
inspired by that
um okay but what's the distributional
inversion inverter
um well what's uh standard inverter for
a recorded one-way function
um given some output y of that function
it's supposed to produce a pre-image of
Y
um seems a little bit harder for a
distributional inverter and that it has
to produce a nearly uniformly random
pre-image of Y so any arbitrary
pre-image wouldn't be good enough
um
this paper shows that the two Notions
are actually essentially equivalent and
luckily for us
um under our assumption we have
distributional inverters for all
polytime computable functions that's
shown in a work of ellender at all
um Okay so
let's back to this problem of random
right hand side refutation we're trying
to learn over a distribution D which is
sample by a poly size circuit c what
does that mean it means the distribution
D is identical to the distribution of C
applied to the uniform distribution
which is the definition of a sampler
um and we're given some samples x i with
labels p i
what do we do well we take a
distributional inverter for that circuit
C
that samples D and we apply it to the
first X part of each one of our samples
and then just from the definitions of d
and c and by the property of
distributional inversion we get like
some simulated samples RI comma bi where
the RIS are now nearly uniformly random
and yeah we just keep the same bis with
the corresponding our eyes
okay so just reviewing the problem we
want to solve this top one
um in the correlative case we know that
the bis are correlated with the outputs
of f over the distribution d
um down below here I'm not doing
anything I'm just restating this so this
statement is exactly equivalent to this
statement
um this distribution D is just the
distribution of C applied to the uniform
distribution
okay so that's just a rewriting
um we apply the transformation to the
sample so that I mentioned earlier and
you can see how this kind of
um sets up a new problem of refutation
which is happening over the uniform
distribution
and we know we have an algorithm solving
the bottom problem
now I'm just going to claim that the
answers to the bottom problem are still
correct with respect to the top problem
now in the random case it's easy to see
that in the random case will still be
random at the bottom in the correlative
case Okay so they're correlated with a
small
um circuit F done in this case the
outputs are still correlated with
another small circuit namely F composed
with C okay so output correlative and
it's the right answer
that's it so that's how the proof goes
for K capital T just a couple open
problems which I think are very
obviously unresolved by this work
um one would be to try to do away with
that kind of strong
access to the distribution that we
require in the case of allenders KT
um I don't know of any reason why we
shouldn't be able to do that other than
just not knowing how
um and then the bottom one is probably
like a bigger problem but it would be
great to get from natural properties to
learning just from random examples
um I'm like vaguely aware that there
would be some implications in
cryptography to do with uh construction
of weak prfs and certain circuit classes
are there any questions
about the question so like can uh c-i-k
we showed like versions of like mcsp for
different natural properties for weaker
circuit classes would it make sense to
look at
um KT for weaker kinds of algorithms
um
and see whether it actually is plausible
to come up with you know can we come up
with a weaken up type of algorithm that
we could actually come up with a
heuristic for KT
yeah I think it's a good question I mean
it's kind of one like obvious
disadvantage of going to KT rather than
circuit sizes so that it doesn't really
fit into like known proof sub circuit
lower bounds or anything like that but I
think it'd be a good direction to
explore
[Music]
yeah
foreign
coffee break and then we'll resume that
um
320 bucks